في نوفمبر ، من المقرر أن تستضيف مصر
أكبر مؤتمر حول تغير المناخ في
كأس العالم 27 وهنا في القاهرة ،
ريادة الأعمال المستدامة هي كل ما
يخبرنا به أحد المستثمرين الملائكيين لماذا
يتجه رواد الأعمال حاليًا
إلى البيئة على أمل تحقيق عوائد كبيرة ليس فقط من
الناحية المالية ولكن أيضًا من أجل الإيثار.
يسمونه القرش المصري ، لا
أعرف ، أعني أن الناس يعتقدون أنني
صارم للغاية وهكذا لأن خالد إسماعيل
يعرف شيئًا أو اثنين حول ما يجعل شركة
ناشئة جيدة حكمًا على النسخة العربية
من دبابة القرش اليوم  لا يبحث صندوق رأس المال الاستثماري
الخاص به عن عائد مربح فحسب ، بل يبحث أيضًا عن عائد
صديق للبيئة نحن محظوظون جدًا لأن معظم
الشركات الناشئة التي استثمرنا فيها كان لها
تأثير جيد لأننا نبحث عن التأثير
أيضًا ، لذا في بعض الأحيان
لا يكون المكاسب المالية هي الشيء الوحيد الذي
يوجد  المقايضة ونحن نقبل
ذلك بالطبع نريد كسب المال في
النهاية ولكنك تعرف ما إذا لم يكن 10x أو
50x ولكن 2X فقط ومع ذلك كان له تأثير جيد
على المجتمع وما إلى ذلك
يجعلنا أيضًا سعداء.  بعد أن
نجح في بيع شركته البرمجية التي تتخذ من القاهرة مقراً لها
لشركة Intel في عام 2011 ، كان من
الممكن أن يتقاعد خالد ، لكنه بدلاً من ذلك أراد
الاستثمار في الجيل القادم من
رواد الأعمال الشباب في مصر ، فإن 60٪
من السكان تقل أعمارهم عن 30 عامًا
وفقًا لإحصاءات الحكومة.
لست مستعدًا للقيام برحلة صعبة أخرى مدتها سبع سنوات
وما إلى ذلك ، ولكن اسمحوا لي أن
أعيد للناس والشباب كل
الخبرة التي تعلمتها تعيدها ، لقد
خصصت بعض المال الذي كان
من ربح البيع للقيام بذلك وفي
البداية  في الواقع لم يكن من أجل الربح
من إدارة النفايات إلى
النفايات الإلكترونية إلى زيت الطهي القابل لإعادة الاستخدام ،
تشتهر شركة خالد بالاستثمار في
الشركات الناشئة التي تدعي أنها
صديقة للبيئة ،
وهي مرة أخرى التحولات السريعة للجزء التقني
التي تعرفها التطبيق وكل
هذه الأشياء بينما تعرف  جهد أكثر
استدامة
يستغرق بناءه خمس سبع سنوات
ويحتاج إلى تدفق نقدي وكل
ذلك لا يظهر عادةً على شاشة الرادار
للعديد من VCS ، لذلك نحن  يجب أن يكون
المحيط أزرق بالنسبة لنا لنصبح معروفين
كمستثمرين في هذا المجال ، وهذا صحيح بما فيه الكفاية ،
هذا ما حدث في إدارة النفايات على
وجه الخصوص ، استثمرنا
في خمس شركات ناشئة
، كان أولها طريقة وقود الديزل الحيوي ، قابل
محمود الركاب ، جاءت لحظة آها.
في محطة بنزين في المملكة المتحدة عندما
رأى وقود الديزل الحيوي معروضًا ،
لا يمكن قول الشيء نفسه في مصر الآن ، لقد
كرس حياته المهنية لتغيير ذلك
، ويقول محمود إن الإجابة يمكن العثور عليها
في مطبخ الجميع ، فنحن منتجون للوقود الحيوي لم يعد
مستخدمًا.  يعتبر زيت الطهي وجميع
زيوت نفايات الديزل الحيوي بديلاً
تمامًا للديزل البترولي الذي يشغل
المحركات التجارية وجميع المرابط
بينما يتوفر زيت الطهي المستخدم
بسهولة في مصر ، فمن المكلف
تحويله إلى وقود ديزل حيوي ، وتكاليف وقود الديزل
الحيوي حاليًا أعلى بنسبة 70 إلى 130 في المائة
من البنزين.  والديزل في مصر
يتم دعم الديزل من قبل الحكومة ، لذا
فإن سوقه في الوقت الحالي هو أوروبا حيث
تفرض تفويضات الاتحاد الأوروبي استخدام الوقود الحيوي
في السوق الأوروبية ضخمة.
حجم السوق 14.2 مليار دولار يقول محمود إن
قرب مصر من أوروبا يجعل
أعماله اللوجستية قابلة للتطبيق ، فنحن في
وسط العالم ، لذا فهي فرصة جيدة
يعتقد أن شركته
التي تنتج 90 طنًا متريًا من
وقود الديزل الحيوي يوميًا يمكن أن تساعد مصر في أن
تصبح رائدة في السوق  في هذا الفضاء
لكنني لا آمل أن تكون شركتي فقط
أكبر أو المنتج الأول
فنحن أكبر منطقة أمينو
نعرفها الآن ولكن أتمنى أن تكون مصر
هي الدولة التي أنتمي إليها ستكون
أكبر منتج  من بين خمسة أنواع من الوقود في
العالم ، إنها ليست الشركة بل هي
البلد الذي
يوافق عليه خالد إسماعيل ويعتقد أن
مخاض النبي ليس بالضرورة
أن يكون ضارًا للكوكب ، فنحن
نعلم جميعًا أنك تعرف كمية أقل من ثاني أكسيد الكربون أو أي
شيء أفضل للعالم ولكنك تعلم
هناك ثمن لذلك تذهب إلى
المصنع وتقول إن إنتاج ثاني أكسيد الكربون أقل
يقولون إن هذا سيكلفني مليوني
دولار سنويًا لن أفعل ذلك
ولكن إذا كان بإمكانك تحويل ذلك إلى
لتحقيق مكاسب مالية ، فأنت
لست بحاجة إلى إقناعهم
بأنك تفعل ذلك ، بل من أجل البيئة
التي لا تزال تفعل ذلك كأي مؤسسة
لتحقيق مكاسب مالية ، ولكن أثناء قيامك
بذلك بالمناسبة ، فإنك تقلل
انبعاثات الكربون التي تقوم بها بشكل
جيد للبيئة التي تقوم بها بشكل
جيد لمجتمعك وهكذا دواليك